en este vídeo vamos a hacer varias cosas
interesantes vamos a empezar trazando un
segmento ave entonces ahí tenemos el
segmento y déjame llamarle a sus
extremos
y ve y ve muy bien y lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es trazar la media triz de
este segmento es decir una recta que sea
perpendicular y que pase por su punto
medio entonces más o menos va a ser algo
como de este estilo como por ahí vale
entonces esto esto de aquí es un ángulo
recto lo de acá también es un ángulo
recto y esta distancia es igual a esta
distancia bueno a esta media tris vamos
a llamarle l y lo primero que vamos a
probar es que cualquier punto sobre l
equidista de a y debe es decir que la
distancia aa es la misma que la
distancia a b bueno para mostrar esto
vamos a tomarnos un punto c sobre l el
que nosotros querramos deja digamos
digamos este punto de acá vale entonces
ese va a ser el punto ce y como queremos
ver que sea es igual acb a lo mejor vale
la pena trazar esos segmentos déjame
trazar sea y voy a tratar también se ve
bueno al trazar estos segmentos podemos
ver que aquí se forman dos triángulos
del ángulo a este punto medio que vamos
a llamar m es como ponerle así
y c y el triángulo be ms y yo digo que
estos dos triángulos son congruentes
observa a m es igual a b m además aquí
hay un ángulo recto y aquí también y
finalmente c m es igual a sí mismo este
lado es igual a sí mismo entonces por el
criterio lado ángulo ángulo lado tenemos
que estos dos triángulos son congruentes
entonces déjame escribirlo por acá
el triángulo amc amc es congruente al
triángulo el triángulo b
mc esto es por el criterio lado ángulo
lado y entonces esto está bien padre
porque si son triángulos congruentes
entonces cada una de sus partes
correspondientes también es congruente y
así concluimos que hace es congruente
abc estos son los lados correspondientes
vale entonces podemos concluir podemos
concluir
qué hace hace es igual a b c y en
realidad no importa donde haya estado de
verdad pudo haber estado por acá por acá
podríamos tener un set al vez aquí o
aquí o aquí y el argumento hubiera sido
exactamente el mismo bueno ahora vamos a
intentar probar esto al revés es decir
que si tenemos un punto que equidista de
idea entonces ese punto está sobre la
media triz del segmento ba entonces para
eso déjame volver a dibujar el segmento
ave ahí tenemos un segmento por aquí
tenemos a por acá tenemos ve y ahora lo
que sabemos es que hay un punto ce no
sabemos donde digamos por ahí que
equidistante a idv
es decir que si trazamos estos dos
segmentos tienen la misma longitud sí
bueno ya quedó un poquito chueco se hace
entonces sabemos que éste es igual a
este de acá y lo que queremos mostrar es
que este punto ce está sobre la media
triz bueno pues como la media tris es
una línea perpendicular lo que vamos a
hacer es trazar la altura desde ese
entonces déjame tomar
y morado y lo que vamos a hacer es
trazar
trazar una línea desde ce que sea
perpendicular es decir vamos a bajar la
altura bueno eso de bajar es más o menos
como medio relativo porque aquí se está
abajo entonces realmente estamos
subiendo la altura pero bueno la
expresión viene de que de que si nuestro
segmento ave es así entonces y ahí bueno
ya tenemos el punto ce entonces pues sí
si baja verdad si baja una altura pero
bueno estas son cosas cosas del lenguaje
regresemos aquí a las matemáticas
entonces bajamos una altura de c a ave y
al punto donde corta esa altura le vamos
a llamar m entonces el plan para mostrar
que se está en la media triz es ver que
realmente c m la recta por c m es la
media triz o sea que ccm es un segmento
de la media triz y para mostrar eso
tendríamos que ver que en efecto pasa
por el punto medio vaya ya es una recta
perpendicular porque así la construimos
entonces para hacer media tris para
hacer media tris para que esta recta l
sea media triz ya nada más le falta que
a m sea igual a m
bueno pues una vez más tenemos dos
ángulos o más bien dos triángulos que
parecen ser congruentes el m
y el bmc y en efecto son congruentes
porque observa que son triángulos
rectángulos si son triángulos aquí con
ángulo recto ángulo recto comparten la
hipotenusa ac es igual abc y comparten
este lado de acá el lado mc entonces
estos dos triángulos en efecto son
congruentes lo voy a poner acá por el
criterio por el criterio recto recto
lado hipotenusa
vale entonces por el criterio recto la
hipotenusa tenemos que el triángulo amc
amc es congruente al triángulo bmc el
triángulo b
mc y entonces todas sus partes
correspondientes miden lo mismo y así
tenemos que bm es igual
a n entonces esto de aquí nos permite
concluir que bm es igual a m y eso es
justo lo que necesitábamos para que ese
m fuera una media triz y bueno no
importa dónde esté el punto c este
argumento se puede repetir vale bueno
entonces ya tenemos dos cosas
interesantes acerca de puntos
equidistantes a los extremos de un
segmento y la media triz del segmento
vale lo que vamos a hacer ahora es
utilizar ese con esos conocimientos que
acabamos de descubrir en un triángulo
entonces déjame pintar por aquí un
triángulo abc de color de color blanco
vale entonces aquí tenemos un triángulo
abc más o menos algo de este estilo y lo
que vamos a hacer es dibujar
cada una de las media tristes entonces
vamos a pintar una media tres por acá
déjame pintar la más o menos así
y ching creo que este caso se acerca
mucho a un caso especial que queremos
ver después porque este ángulo es casi
un ángulo recto entonces sabes qué mejor
déjame borrar este triángulo y mejor en
el en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
platicar de de el caso especial del caso
especial de los triángulos rectángulos
entonces mejor voy a hacer un triángulo
un poco un poco menos especial un
triángulo pues más o menos así y así van
entonces ya todos los ángulos son
menores a 90 y ahora si este triángulo
lo voy a llamar el triángulo abc aquí
tenemos a aquí tenemos de aquí tenemos c
y voy a trazar cada una de las media
tristes entonces primero voy a trazar la
de ave déjame trazar la de ave entonces
tiene que pasar por el punto medio voy a
marcar el punto medio como por allí una
y vale este de aquí es igual a éste de
acá y tiene que ser una recta
perpendicular a ave entonces voy a
agarrar este color amarillo
o mejor color rosa que es el de las
media tristes y
voy a hacer una recta perpendicular
bueno voy a hacerlo un poco más larga
vale algo así
entonces ahí tenemos una una media tris
la de ave y ahora vamos a construir otra
media triz la de lado a hacer otra vez
esa media triz debe de pasar por el
punto medio digamos más o menos por ahí
y tiene que ser perpendicular a hace
entonces voy a tomar otra vez el color
de media tristes que es como este morado
y vamos a hacer algo de este estilo
entonces una vez más este ángulo de aquí
es recto y este este segmento de aquí
mide lo mismo que este segmento de acá
bueno observa que estas dos media
tristes se intersectan aquí en un punto
y a este punto en el cual se intersectan
le vamos a poner un nombre vamos a
llamarle el punto o entonces yo digo que
este punto o cumple varias propiedades
interesantes este punto para empezar
está en la media triz de ave entonces
cumple que equidista de ahí debe eso es
justo lo que probamos de este lado
entonces tenemos que la distancia de a a
a- es la misma que la distancia de b
voy a apuntar esto por acá tenemos que a
y es igual a b
pero además este punto o lo construimos
sobre la media triz de hace entonces
también es equidistante de a de c de
esta forma tenemos que a a
es igual a c
pero entonces está padre porque si hago
es igual a veo ya o es igual a cero
también tenemos que veo es igual a c
pero ve eso esto lo que nos dice es que
o es un punto que aquí dista de ve y
dice y entonces ahora nos vamos a este
otro resultado que probamos y con éste
podemos concluir que o es un punto sobre
la media triz de bc y eso está padrísimo
verdad déjame déjame trazar la media
tris voy a trazar la más o menos así a
ver si queda algo de ese estilo sabemos
que aquí es perpendicular perpendicular
y que éste es igual a éste éste es igual
a éste entonces está súper padre porque
estos conocimientos que descubrimos
aplicándolos a un triángulo nos permiten
encontrar un punto que exista de los
tres vértices de un triángulo un único
punto y no sólo eso también nos permite
concluir que ese punto está sobre las
tres media tristes del triángulo o bien
podemos pensarlo al revés acabamos de
demostrar que si tenemos las tres media
tristes del triángulo entonces éstas se
intersectan en un
y junto al cual llamamos a este punto
equidistante los tres vértices bueno
pues resulta que a este punto le
llamamos el círculo centro del triángulo
vale le voy a poner por acá seguir con
un centro sin un centro entonces este es
el circo un centro del triángulo y se
llama decir un centro porque pasa otra
cosa interesante si tomamos una
circunferencia que tiene centro en o y
tiene radio esta distancia que es igual
en los tres casos a o b y c o si tomamos
un círculo con centro aquí entonces es
esta circunferencia va a pasar por a o
por b y por se va bueno pues a este a
esta distancia a esta distancia que es
igual a esta distancia hago que es igual
a veo que es igual a cero le llamamos el
círculo radio el círculo radio
y a este círculo que pasa por estos tres
vértices le vamos a llamar el circo un
círculo o bien circunferencia
circunscrita vale entonces lo puedes
encontrar con diferentes nombres en
diferentes fuentes entonces ahí tenemos
ahí tenemos más o menos verdad no soy
muy bueno dibujando círculos a mano a
mano alzada pero más o menos tenemos
zinc tenemos
el seguir con un círculo círculo
círculo quién sabe que haya sido ese
menú que salió pero bueno va entonces
tenemos este círculo se llama círculo
porque es una circunferencia
circunscrita a abc esto es de
circunscrita es que pasa por los tres
vértices entonces pues ya tenemos muchos
círculos verdad
esta circunstancia que es una
circunferencia circunscrita consiste
justamente en tomarse el circo un centro
y tomar todos los puntos que están a
distancia el círculo radio vale bueno
entonces le voy a dejar hasta aquí y nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo